the show in a lot of ways how it was  constructed when i talked to the other  cast members that that i sat down with  one of the questions that i asked  everybody was about the last line of the  show and what that meant to them and  clearly greg daniels the creator wrote  the last episode so he wrote the last  line and the last line goes something  like why did they decide to do a  documentary about a paper company it's  about beauty in ordinary things isn't  that kind of the point  and i think that that  celebration of the ordinary for the  office that sel that these people have  meaning we spoiler alert we weren't like  friends right like we weren't like on  the cover of cosmo and doing all of the  glamorous stuff i'm talking about the  actors too who were on the show right we  were a group of ordinary people who were  assembled by a great casting director to  work together in this place and and that  celebration i think is what what  responds to people